Coast to Coast with stories that matter
most
you're watching local news with
nine-time Emmy Award winner Chet van
Jansen and now
here's chat
yes that was strange it's local news
where each guest has to share a story
from wherever they're from and then I
vote on the winner and that person gets
to pick from our Caesar salad showcase
that was a weird thing yes
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
where is where is the actual Caesar
salad showcase uh you know we've looked
into it but it's uh it's hard to
determine but I Gotta Go My chariots
double parked
what a jokester all right
so if I like your story you're going to
get that Caesar salad I'm gonna you know
what I'm gonna go first To You Paul
because you've never played this game
local video games
go ahead yeah what's your local story oh
I got to give the stories I got to do
that too yeah all right okay
apparently New York City has appointed a
rat Czar right right so let me unpack
this real quickly for you these are the
new positions and you know we'll run out
of time office of Asylum Seeker
operations office of faith-based
Community Partnerships mayor's office
for child protection I could go on yeah
14 or 15 new czars in New York City
since we got our new mayor all of them
need staff all of them need computers
all of them will have pensions all of
them want to go on strike so the cat's
Point government just grows it's just
the amoeba that's eating the city and
now we have a radsar and yesterday I saw
my first wreck do you know your first
round my first ride in my neighborhood I
should say yeah I hadn't seen one in a
good long time and I saw one yesterday
so there's a there's a fact that and it
looked like a lemur man it was gigantic
do you know in New York City that you
are always within 20 feet feet of two
rats having sex oh really
that's according to a book on Rats the
homeless so somewhere in this room yeah
somewhere in this room
there are at least two rats having sex
keep it down rats
anyway
that's that's good stuff all right Dr
true uh your last time we played we
played this you made me cry no no no I'm
sorry it's not a bummer but this one's
uh pretty simple and believe it or not
common in Los Angeles someone got so
frustrated with the way the roads were
working just turned around on the
freeway there it is and we do this there
it's it's frequent enough in Los Angeles
that we have these electronic Billboards
that you will frequently say someone
going the wrong way on the freeway now
not all of it is just strictly out of
frustration we have some video on this
here too but I can't tell you how often
I feel like doing that it is all the
time our roads do not work we have no
water we have no safety but people are
getting fed up so the person just there
it is they're at the film video our
producers are doing a great job right
now just turns around good job yeah all
right just had enough yeah but by the
way gridlock's like that they're
surprisingly common and the CHP has no
problem letting them sit like that for
hours sometimes that's incredible you I
mean you would go absolutely nuts you
always have to have a little picnic
basket in your car always I always do if
to keep the human head
[Laughter]
um I go to you last
my story
it's about sea lions the only thing
bigger than a sea lion is the size of
this colossal
take a look oh wow
they look like
[Music]
oh
get back
him and his Bros were like laughing and
cheering but meanwhile the crowds were
like you total jerk leave them alone go
to jail go to prison so the irony is
probably there in in California where
dresses is backwards he'll see more jail
time than like the violent thugs that we
see robbing people on the streets just
before he did that a pretty good
backflip he chugged like a Mountain Dew
like he shotgunned it and then his Pros
were like you can do it but all he did
was disturb these adorable sea lions so
he's probably gonna be Bud light's next
influencer there you go
poor little sea lions I know yeah what
did they ever do cats oh they do a lot
you'd be surprised oh really oh yeah
like what they um defecate on boats all
the time people have to really work yeah
where do you expect us to defecate they
make huge messes in Harbors they live
there that's their natural habitat not
the first world problem yes all right
cat Michigan it is in Detroit last week
on the streets there was a pony really
and the pony had no owner and therein
lies the mystery
a week ago there was a pony just walking
around Detroit and they still haven't
found the owner of the pony wow who
loses a pony
and then forgets that they ever had a
pony yeah you know there's got to be
something going on here first there's
the shoes in Oakland County yeah it's a
and now there's a pony yeah I call that
single horsepower yeah the Roomba that
escaped it's it's getting crazy and now
the the the pony is just staying at
Abraham ranch right you know and
nobody's claimed their Pony and I really
want to know if you're missing a Pony
um why
I heard that Schwarzenegger was getting
tired of his Pony maybe this is what he
did with it I mean I feel like if you
have Pony resources you are like Pony up
you you you have resources to deal with
you don't just like let a pony loose I
don't know who won I saw this before
Hell's Kitchen I saw a horse walk by me
oh no no no that was Joy Behar no this
was a big wreck
yes
terrible
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else